alright guys so new Batman pictures
released I usually don't talk about
these kind of things but every once in a
while I just get really inspired by The
Dark Knight Rises it's such a big movie
coming out this year this year Wow see
even saying that right now it's just so
many expectations the Entertainment
Weekly that comes out tomorrow features
a new cover with the new Batman suit and
a really good look at it and more than
likely they'll be new pictures inside
I'm probably gonna pick up the magazine
just so I can read it in the bathtub
moving on now we've seen the new bat
suit before it looks great this is a
really great high-def look I'm not
noticing too many changes from The Dark
Knight The Dark Knight did a really cool
thing when it updated his neck for so he
could turn it more and not be like H all
right all right all God know one of the
cool things that no one said in the
article is that he really feels the
immense pressure from Dark Knight he's
not taking it lightly he's very very
particular when it comes to pleasing
fans and that's one of the reasons I
love Nolan and that's really a sign of a
good director as a win they're not just
making movies because this is what I
want to do they really care about the
audience's experience he also encouraged
fans to go back and look at the end of
the Dark Knight where Batman and
Commissioner Gordon cooked up this plot
to hide Harvey Dent's sins so that more
than likely is gonna have a big play in
the film one of the cool things about
Christopher Nolan's style and directing
these movies is that he makes it
realistic he puts it in a world that
seems real Batman Begins really
showcased a world just filled with crime
The Dark Knight took that to a whole new
levels on which it explored morality
terrorism all kinds of really deep
subjects and it seems like the Dark
Knight Rises is gonna take a little bit
of a political aspect in which all the
pictures I've seen if Tom Hardy holding
up pictures of Harvey Denton just seems
like it's really gonna go for a very
realistic feel in this comic book world
which is what makes these movies
fantastic in regards to Bane's voice
Christopher Nolan recently released a
new audio portion to go with the Dark
Knight Rises prologue that's already
playing in theaters he didn't tweak
Bane's voice at all he just lessened the
base and the sound quality of the
airplane which i think is perfect
because looking back really that was the
thing that kind of overshadowed almost
everything that everyone was saying so
that was a good choice definitely very
much looking forward to the Dark Knight
Rises the new picture looks awesome what
do you guys think of the new picture
what do you think of the movie in
general I am freaking out about it as
you know but
turn it down so that I may survive these
next few months let me know what you
think below later tonight I'm gonna see
contraband and I will have that review
up for you then if you like this update
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck mine eyes